[Music]
are you as good at things as you think
you are how good are you at managing
money
what about reading people's emotions how
healthy are you compared to other people
you know are you better than average at
grammar knowing how competent we are and
how our skills stack up against other
peoples is more than a self-esteem boost
it helps us figure out when we can forge
ahead on our own decisions and instincts
and when we need instead to seek out
advice but psychological research
suggests that were not very good at
evaluating ourselves accurately in fact
we frequently overestimate our own
abilities
researchers have a name for this
phenomenon the dunning-kruger effect
this effect explains why more than a
hundred studies have shown that people
display illusory superiority we judge
ourselves as better than others to a
degree that violates the laws of math
when software engineers at two companies
were asked to rate their performance
thirty-two percent of the engineers at
one company and 42 percent at the other
put themselves in the top 5% in another
study 88% of American drivers described
themselves as having above-average
driving skills these are isolated
findings on average people tend to rate
themselves better than most in
disciplines ranging from health
leadership skills ethics and beyond
what's particularly interesting is that
those with the least ability are often
the most likely to overrate their skills
to the greatest extent
people measurably poor at logical
reasoning grammar financial knowledge
math emotional intelligence running
medical lab tests and chess all tend to
rate their expertise almost as favorably
as actual experts do so whose most
vulnerable to this delusion
sadly all of us because we all have
pockets of incompetence we don't
recognize but why when psychologists
Dunning and Kruger first described the
effect in 1999 they argued that people
lacking knowledge and skill in
particular areas suffer a double curse
first they make mistakes and reach poor
decisions but second those same
knowledge gaps also prevent them from
catching their errors in other words
poor performers lack the very expertise
needed to recognize how badly they're
doing for example when the researchers
studied participants in a college debate
tournament the bottom 25% of teams in
preliminary rounds lost nearly four out
of every five matches but they thought
they were winning almost 60% without a
strong grasp of the rules of debate the
students simply couldn't recognize when
or how often their arguments broke down
the dunning-kruger effect isn't a
question of ego blinding us to our
weaknesses people usually do admit their
deficits once they can spot them in one
study students who had initially done
badly on a logic quiz and then took a
mini course on logic were quite willing
to label their original performances as
awful that may be why people with a
moderate amount of experience or
expertise often have less confidence in
their abilities they know enough to know
that there's a lot they don't know
meanwhile experts tend to be aware of
just how knowledgeable they are but they
often make a different mistake they
assume that everyone else is
knowledgeable too
the result is that people whether
they're inept or highly skilled are
often caught in a bubble of inaccurate
self perception when they're unskilled
they can't see their own faults when
they're exceptionally competent they
don't perceive how unusual their
abilities are so if the dunning-kruger
effect is invisible to those
experiencing it what can you do to find
out how good you actually are at various
things
first ask for feedback from other people
and consider it even if it's hard to
hear second and more important keep
learning the more knowledgeable we
become the less likely we are to have
invisible holes in our competence
perhaps it all boils down to that old
proverb when arguing with a fool first
make sure the other person isn't doing
the same thing did you enjoy this lesson
if so please consider supporting our
nonprofit mission by visiting
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]